[Music]
the school of design at Carnegie Mellon
is very humanistic design program how do
we make people's lives better when
students come here and they come here
and they learn kind of that rich
tradition of design I really wanted to
get a feel for what it would be like and
also I think it's different because it's
not a it's not an art school you know
and so you get a little bit more of a
technical feel that was so cool because
it was like it you even in the first
week in the first few days I had learned
I had learned so much about about how
the process works we have a group of two
TAS that kind of chaperone the group
oftentimes so you might take a trip to a
museum and there'll be conversations
afterwards about the artwork that's
hanging on the wall it's really
interesting because how different
they're from high school teachers
because they're very personal with you
and they want you to they allow you to
explore different ideas they definitely
get to know each student and like you
get to know the teacher and you get to
know that they definitely love to do
what they do
Carnegie Mellon does a really good job
getting different kinds of people here
different viewpoints that actually make
for a really nice teaching environment
in a learning environment because you
get different ideas coming from
different place if you cannot draw at
all and you feel like you're not going
to be able to keep up with other
students that's completely fine that's
what you're here to learn we're here to
teach you we're here to make you a
better drawer or better photographer or
a better three-dimensional designer
that's what we're here for so if you're
really excited about what you're doing
it doesn't matter who you are and what
skills you have just come here have fun
the little things that make it really
enjoy rolling and make it a lot of fun
and it's fun to discover in new places
and meet new people and get away from
you know what's normal and discover
something new even if you're not really
sure if you want to go into design I
think it's a great way to to try to
figure that out and I just it's a great
way to spend your summer and
and it's a lot of fun
[Music]